hello in one of the co plane or stunts
here in last game was a win I didn't
uploaded my opponent and blundered a big
porn like on move seven or something and
resigned so there was a little point in
in uploading this video um was like 30
seconds of a game so here against
Austin's um Queen ef3 this nowadays all
the rage don't ask me why they play this
move that'sthat's trial one funny thing
is that we should a 3 is actually answer
to that it's not good yet but if you
want to look at something which is
completely crazy this fits the bill um
okay so let's see what Austin's is doing
here we would I don't even know this was
the right move Castle action is what
city here with create free some g45
maybe that could that could happen right
g4 set move aside move maybe it does
this make some sense yeah 95 then Queen
g3 or queen h3 a detector sir oh so I
can just do that oh I like the slide at
least now I know what to do click for
mates I don't know if that that's going
to be wow is that working looks a little
bit loose here with the diagonal well
okay my night doesn't have great squares
a4 looks wrong I was thinking it here
might be some tech deck like night f5
takes Knight d5 this kind of thing could
work you know what next to it let's do
it maybe you just ignores it in place
before but yeah that probably isn't
isn't such a huge concern before I can
maybe anyway now we know we know it's on
now that I think of it maybe can cook
you to a five it threatened to take yeah
maybe funny so maybe the objective
merits of the sacrifice but actually
quite they're quite questionable Oh down
anyway Oh anyway I'll take care p 7 I
don't know that law doesn't look like
very ammonius development to me no I'm
threatening f6e em okay this must be
enough compensation I'm pretty sure
maybe not yeah but should be six that
was maybe not
and I need to play this I think if he
takes my knight on d5 this will be too
little now no I was thinking I had
enough but I didn't didn't really
consider this correctly this is still
dangerous in a practical game but
objectively I should be worse here much
worse okay do I threaten come to you
fall mm-hmm maybe now well you know well
this is not I didn't think about this so
much it's critical as h 5 + f4 will will
will come with tempo 97 or what's what's
what's going on taking on f6 I'm very
okay the pawn takes King take so that
should be five probably at age five is
good okay night before this is ideal
okay waiting for word for word so h6
doesn't do it if a form a vm for young
night before
sinking taking c3 maybe or rock detune
mm-hmm my rock is hanging head ago an h1
no game okay okay okay so look takes it
too is that how much of a threat is that
pretty substantial gun okay oh my god
this is this am not unhappy about to say
the least I actually have a double check
here and i have this check or that
doesn't do all that much
I know this is actually take some time
it takes it i also have g16 don't know
where this is going hi morning let's do
it come on I have to play click on you
create this stuff Bishop takes d4 I th7
and then kill King age eight I don't
know about this it could still be okay
Wow $98 check and I'll take you there do
I don't see it made again the double
check it goes there I don't think I
don't see you make it which is kind of
crazy so double check I take their
double check again can you have seven
where's the maid katsia made g7 maybe a
sec meeting okay I just takes it he just
takes it long I don't want to draw yeah
this is crazy come on Jack King do seven
saving him yeah maybe aa should have
probably taken the draw I have knives
I've got nine seconds on the clock I
just couldn't bring myself to end this
game and let him escape them but okay I
showed him
is all kinds of stuff yeah yeah okay I
should take the draw them even though
they write resides with a like a huge
likelihood there's some chick made that
I didn't see of course so so how am i
meeting him cactus okay Catton's I can
do shattuck cringy so cat jigs and the
queen is unprotected like it's
unprotected I'm such a [ __ ] yeah I can
just win the Queen Oh sometimes I can oh
yeah well okay this was a extremely
incorrect game probably but yeah I
wanted to try the sacrifice the engine
is actually saying before and um hmm
well again it's it's a blitz game and I
knew it was probably going to be a bit
dicey Queen a five year that was indeed
the problem as I already suspect
suspected but amazingly enough it's not
like giving a total win for black this
looks kind of weird
yeah I'm in a position like that is
indeed not so clear especially not with
humans playing what CUNY for like a not
avoid the Queen traders tricky this I
identify four months okay so here the
situation is extremely unclear and in a
blitz game f6 know that looked what you
should do right here I really didn't
know what's going on and you also cannot
really trust the engine after like a
couple of seconds in a position like
that it's just so so crazy I mean I'm a
I'm a full-piece down for porn but the
evaluation is is roughly equal let's say
so that means that there is some kind of
compensation yeah I went here okay
Queenie for was supposed to be better oh
that look normal night before yeah yeah
that was a blonde IM black now should
should win so instead i should play a
queen f4 actually winning but yeah this
is maybe a threat a g6 yeah also what
the engine gives back here and i'm
breaking through him clap okay night
before I should lose now and he didn't
take their plate this I have to be sure
before I mean that's crazy g6 and now
the engine finds a draw with night a 2
cap King be one night check check I know
it actually says i can sacrifice the sky
and now rookie one
so first of all let's check what is
threatened here age six is the threat
yeah this is checkmate an immediate made
check yeah check checkmate mate on age
seven aware that it was took two Quick
now yeah so we had this honor in takes
cat and now it seems he has to give up
the Queen yeah he doesn't have a doesn't
have a queen move to prevent this age
six business this is probably really
winning the engine gives a wide Wynette
still complete mess but ok and this
happened and now we are we have this
line that cat that should win take off
top and repeat I should make the drawn
our 19 seconds I didn't see a win so I
should make the draw I just hate to do
it in a position where I know that I
should win somehow but I don't know you
don't know how what to do it yeah I came
back and just take the Queen I don't
know I he had the screen protected I'm
from and Anwar Indian k this actually
also wins after Bishop Jake's don't
quite know why actually Queen takes me
six is threatened they're probably hmm
93 what kind of a move is that so if he
does that winning in the attack navin
okay not with
second try yeah it's a complete mess
yeah every time I should make the wrong
it's just that I'm totally hated to make
a draw and I think I'm summer winning
even if I as I don't see the way okay
what a funny game anyway thanks for
watching